let's start right from the get-go this
is adorable and awesome and what nothing
the poster behind you thank you
right exactly so I wanted to actually I
met your dog out in the hallway yes I
love animals and so this whole interview
became something different than what I
was expecting what is her name her name
is Tian foo she it's it's it's very
Chinese and she is Chinese she's a
Chinese rescue dog and she's from China
right so I have to ask because I'm
always fascinated help people connected
with their animals yeah how did you guys
meet I went to the store there's like
local market to buy some sugar because I
was making candy for Christmas and I
went to the store and there was a
Chinese lady there who had all these
rescue dogs from China and I was like oh
I didn't want to go talk so bad and but
I can't take any of those dogs they were
too big and she just went I have more
dogs in the car so like like she's
selling me VCRs out of her van she opens
it and there's all these dogs and there
was tea on foo with her little scarred
mouth
somebody had tied a wire around her
mouth and thrown her in the garbage and
she was so sad and I picked her up and I
started crying and a couple hundred
dollars later it's like no paperwork I
have this dog this is pre coronavirus so
don't send me your hate mail right um
when did you guys meet each other the
long just before Christmas
oh so this is very recent just before
Christmas it was a bourbon Christmas
gift
um that dog is adorable she's a good
girl right exactly jumping into it now
why I get to talk to you okay but I love
this this is fantastic great for me um
you got you worked with mark on instant
family with is a strong word I was there
for exactly still McCall she but what
I'm saying is like did that play any
part in and getting into Spencer or is
it just like I don't think it did I
because we had no even though we were in
the same scenes together for for for
instant family even though we were in
the same scenes together all my scenes
had him in it for instant family we
didn't have any shared dialogue or
shared moments we didn't talk I think
this was I got this part because they
liked it but it even in the call with
him later he was like I know we didn't
really get to talk and instant family
I'm like yeah I was eating lunch in a
communal lunchroom and you were like in
a mansion eating your lunch so we're not
on the same level but yeah
is it more nerve-wracking
filming a sex scene with Mark Wahlberg
or walking out on stage to do stand-up
1000% more nerve-wracking to film a sex
scene with Mark Wahlberg I had no no
touchstone there's no context to compare
that to stand-up I've done I don't get
nervous for that anymore I just get
excited and I was very excited to do the
sex scene but terrified because there's
no school for actors for bathroom sex
scenes so I just went into it fingers
crossed that I wasn't the one who messed
up and it was it got easier the more we
did it and that's the way sexist I
believe you wrote a movie I did and I'm
very I don't think it has a title and I
don't know anything about it does it
have a title and what can you tease
people about I hope to be calling it
cuttlefish and it is based on it's a
true story based on a lot it's a it's a
mostly true story based on a lie anybody
who's a super fan of mine might know the
story that I'm referencing it's about a
girl who goes out with a guy who ends up
not being what he says he was and then
the girls decide to take revenge but
don't actually do it so it's that so
it's an anti rom-com got it and when
will people be able to see it do you
know hopefully soon got it that's all I
can tell you we just we just picked
you're locked
we haven't even color corrected it yet
but um we shall see hopefully everybody
loves it on that note
congrats on this and also of finding a
great dog
[Music]